[Music]
just days after russia began its
invasion of ukraine kiev applied to join
the european union four months later eu
leaders at a summit in brussels approved
the request and put ukraine on the path
to future membership we have decided to
grant candidate status to ukraine and
moldova and you are ready to grant
kennedy status to georgia once
priorities will be addressed there can
be no better sign of hope for the
citizens of ukraine moldova and georgia
in these troubled times
ukraine's president vladimir zelinsky
called the eu's decision a unique and
historical moment in relations
we have just received the european union
candidacy this is a victory we've been
waiting for this for 120 days of the war
and even 30 years of our independence
it usually takes years for a country to
gain candidate status after applying
some eu officials said fast-tracking the
process would prove the block solidarity
with ukraine as it defends itself
against russian attacks a sentiment
echoed by the head of ukraine's mission
to the eu at a gathering in the city
it's important
for the whole country for the whole
society and it's important also for the
ukrainian army
to have a clear reason
what we are fighting for we are fighting
for the future we are fighting for the
modern independent sovereign european
country becoming a candidate country is
only a step to be granted membership is
a long an arduous process that could
take many years
some western balkan countries have been
waiting for more than a decade for
progress on their eu bids leaders from
the region were also in brussels to urge
eu officials to speed up the process
north macedonia albania serbia and
montenegro are all candidate countries
that want to achieve full membership
we definitely support the candidacy
status for ukraine we also support the
candidates status for moldova we are
very thrilled that georgia is also being
given a european perspective but we also
ask our european partners not to
forget about or leave the western
balkans behind
[Applause]
the eu's approval of kiev's candidacy
sends a strong message not only to
ukraine but also to russia that despite
moscow's firepower and efforts kiev is
determined to look west
natasha butler al jazeera brussels
[Applause]